you directed your brother in a sex scene
with Charlize Theron's
now that's got to be strange you know
what I mean yeah well I would have all
kinds of envy in that situation but you
know still it's also gonna be weird to
be watching your brother and be
directing him in that scenario you know
I don't really want to know what my
brother's moves on behind closed doors
and then you know I also you know like
as a director you're encouraging the
actors to do things and then I'm like am
I supposed to be egging my brother on in
this moment like yeah yeah so you know I
was trying to find the balance of you
know being the director and not being
the brother and then watching my brother
do this thing with Charlize and it's a
it's a it's a tricky balance to strike
yeah all right we have a clip here from
from gringo and this is not the sex
scene no
how how would I get that we'll talk
about that later put on my phone oh yeah
so I look like your brother so I could
you know anyway it can be a wreck you
see what I'm getting it yeah yeah target
for role playing ping tell us about this
scene in ingria your your your brother
and charlize theron they don't play very
likeable characters yeah they're kind of
these corporate pharmaceutical bosses
and they're a little bit ignorant and
they've just arrived in Mexico City for
the first time and this is them arriving
at the airport with Harold they're their
underling who is taking them on a
business trip I he's like couldn't
couldn't couldn't be a nicer guy let's
take a look at this scene from gringo
introduce again what what does that
smell
I thought we is barbecue I always bring
a stranger
in jail windows bs here you go yes allow
me to introduce our co-presidents mr.
Rusk and Miss Markinson la new app
amazing know what else missing is
actually learning a foreign language
you know Taco Bell huh ad sensational
[Applause]
you